Nhưng mà nhớ cuộc thương đồn này mà đã cụ biểu ngưu khi họ làm
bởi lắm, mình chắc hả?
thì thế thì đấy cũng là mà phải lợi trọt để có thể phân cuộc thêm.
Nếu mà thương đồ tiếp, tiếp trục cảo thái,
thì các hay thân nghiệp lên qua đến ở bệnh trải thâu khi,
ở bệnh trải biệt, thì về cơ hạn nào họ sẽ được hủy.
Hồi lợi hôi, trước là như thế này thì về cơ hạn nào,
trước đây thì có thể nó đi trứng đường thạm,
bây giờ đó, thương đồ thì có phải đi thể đi phó.
Chúc này này đã thui, để đầu có mùi ngại,
để đầu thương đồ, để lắm rồi.
Hãy đi từ đó là tụi như thế này,
cái nhưu, tầu, nó cao lên rất nhiều.
Để đi các hay thân nghiệp vành trải biển thì họ sẽ cho phê được vương đồ,
giá, phải cao luôn, từ đó là họ sẽ có được cái quả,
bình trải nó, tích được phân.
Còn gặp lại, mùi trụ, phải thân nghiệp đồ khí,
mà họ phải thách đầu và mắm đừng đầu, phóng là,
cái vân thú của họ, lại xin lụ thuộc và trán đầu.
Cứ là có những cái mạnh hợp đồng, nó vân thú là vừa trên trán đầu.
Vì vọ là người như thương đồ khảy ra là nổ thân càng thì họ có thể được vửa,
và có cái quảy ra khách tơi của thế,
tích được khóc.
Mọi người làm trong người của trên,
ở đây là,
thì có thể thấy là một số nóm,
và có phy cũng mình thẳng.
Họ nó có một cái câu,
có ngoài nường đi với cái câu trên này cả.
Thì đã phổ phy của nó,
chỉ có đường đó,
hỏng một rời đến 2,
người phân chạm rồi.
Với 2, người chạm rồi.
Chó khi đến lên đạn,
cái quảy ra nó,
và các cái dự báo với cái quảy ra,
và đại lần nữa, thì chúng ta lại có một vông dù.